[Music]
hello youtube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 30th
episode of my chest strap series in this
episode I'm going to show you one of the
high profile trap in the French exchange
volition from the white perspective you
the opening arises after the following
order evil a 6 d 4 D 5 and here white
has plenty of choices but amongst them
we are looking at he captures d fire and
after a captors defy we reach to the
starting point of the French exchange
volition now this opening is very common
amongst beginner to intermediate level
and specially below 1600 to numb in
practice pay special attention guys as
the trap I am going to show you not only
occurs by the most frequent more orders
but even though let's say your opponent
doesn't fall for the traps you still get
a wonderful attacking position here
white should start with Knight to f3 and
it doesn't matter whether you open and
continue with Bishop to d6 or Knight to
f6 let's say in this game black continue
with Bishop to d6 and after that my
recommendation is you should play this
aggressive move c4 immediately hitting
black center well black is more than
happy as he's going to take the spoon
and after Bishop captures c4 black can
argue that he has created an isolated
queen pawn in the white game which can
be a clear-cut target in the middle King
that's true but the other side of the
coin is white get a free piece play and
that we are about to see first it's all
about King safety so very naturally both
decide we'll take out the King side
piece and then castle
on the kingside well afterwards white
will continue with Knight to c3 and
generally speaking you play this move
after the MU h3 as this Bishop to g4 pin
is very annoying and no wonder your
opponent eyes will literally lit up as
he can play the move Bishop to g4 pin
down the knight and also putting
pressure on the d4 square okay no issues
we are going to hit back this Bishop
with h3 and very naturally black would
like to keep that pin so Bishop to h5
here white has tried various responses
but I'm going to propose this aggressive
move
g4 hitting the bishop one more time then
obviously here the Knight captures g4
doesn't work the simple reason is after
H captures g4 and Bishop captures G fool
but can simply play Queen to d3 unpin
denied and even though black has to pawn
against a piece i don't think so there
is enough compensation and as it
confirmed by engine this position is
better for the white camp so that means
here black responses force black has to
play Bishop to g6 and after that white
reveal his cunning idea behind playing
the mu h 3g for he wants to prong this
wonderful night at the center of the
board and even though white King is
somewhat opener once what will get
either of the bishop he will opt in the
bishop pair and in a long roll this
gives him better winning chances
now another cute point behind the moon
night to efface White has set up a
cunning trap at this point and many
black players has fallen into it black
and try the various responses but the
move he should not played his c5 which
to the naked eye it looks very obvious
in this position black wants to
undermine the d4 pawn and then get rid
of that pesky night well okay that's on
surface looks so cool but in fact after
this move black is instantly losing now
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out the sequence
where actually white obtained are
completely open engage okay then let's
see how this wonderful trap springs up
the first mode is very obvious Knight
captures g6 black responses force black
has to take with the Ashbourne
afterwards we are going to take the C
pawn attacking the bishop so once again
black response is very obvious Bishop
captures c5 and after that I hope you
see this deciding blow so suddenly from
nowhere white munch upon and at this
point black cannot even take with the
route as his own Queen Hanks so if black
doesn't want to be a pawn down then he
has to pick with the king and for a time
being black is a piece up
but after Wyatt's next reply Queen to b3
that poor King cannot hide now on the gr
square he has to come out so King to eat
is the only response and after that
white initiative just literally killed
the black rook to even check Bishop e7
is forced as after King to d7
we have mating two guys yep
it's very easy one Queen to e6 check
King to c7 and night to be fine
as a checkmate so black can't even think
about this Bishop to e7 and now comes
the whole point behind this cute trap
White has this winning move in the
picture
Bishop to a fool and no matter how River
black wriggles this game will not last
long
White has a simple idea he wants to play
rook to d1 and then Bishop to d6 and in
some lines if it's required then Knight
to d6 also comes with a devastation all
in all I can say even though black is a
piece of his King will hardly survive in
the upcoming moose now to loose it the
danger in this position I like to show
you one of the quickest win by white at
this point black continue with one of
the best move rook to f7 giving our
protection to the bishop white continue
it very naturally rook to d1 attacking
the Queen and after Queen to b6 black
thought that if the Queen will be
exchanged then he is right back in the
game but what he missed is White's
lethal reply boom so now not only queen
is attacked but what is clearly
threatening rook to d8 checkmate so
black response is very obvious black has
to take this bishop and after that the
sequence is pretty obvious Knight to be
file attacking the Queen and coming at
the juicy d6 square which is not easy to
parry
Queen to b6 happen but after Knight to
d6 Jack Black simply resigns as Black
has to give up the Queen in the view of
Epsilon rook hanks and even after that
once white will take back ok materially
speaking black has 3 minor pieces for a
queen but the problem is his King is
wide open and his minor pieces are not
playing at all a sample line can run
like this Knight B to d7 White will more
than happy to take on b7 and after rook
to d8 and the move g5
once the night moon we can even munch
the a7 pawn and those two distant parcel
on the Queen side can be a big decider
of the game that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful mini trap
in the French exchange variation
once you opponent play the Moosey file
then he is literally asking for the
trouble as White has this lethal winning
move Bishop captures f7 which can
literally kills the black on the spot
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye Anne take care